joe biden réoriente la diplomatie
américaine
retour dans les traités internationaux
hostilité affichée à l'encontre de la
russie
remise en cause du soutien à l'arabie
saoudite depuis son entrée en fonction
le président américain a multiplié les
prises de position avec un objectif
clair rompant avec la stratégie de son
prédécesseur donald trump un choix
réaffirmé dès le début du mois de
février lors de son premier discours sur
la politique internationale prononcé au
département d'état l'amérique est de
retour l'amérique est de retour et la
diplomatie est de retour c est au centre
de tout ce que j'ai l'intention de faire
nous allons réparer nos alliances nous
engager à nouveau avec le monde non pas
pour relever les défis d'hier mais ceux
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
le leadership américain doit faire face
à ce nouveau moment de progression de
l'autoritarisme mais deux mois après
l'investiture de joe biden les décisions
fermes sur les dossiers brûlants se font
attendre
comme par exemple à propos du nucléaire
iranien joe biden a fait du retour des
etats unis dont l'accord devienne une
priorité mais sans actes concrets
washington semble encore bien éloigné de
la table des négociations
une forme d'inaction qui interroge de
plus en plus outre atlantique et qui
fait craindre une aggravation de la
situation
je pense que l'administration maiden a
raté une occasion au cours des premières
semaines de son mandat d'envoyer un
signal plus fort et plus concret de ses
intentions de bonne foi de revenir dans
l'accord de vienne pendant le temps
qu'il a fallu à l'équipe biden pour
commencer à être plus proactive les
positions se sont durcies en iran
surnommé diot l'endormi par donald trump
au cours de la campagne présidentielle
joe biden tente d'afficher des positions
incisive sur la scène internationale
avec le risque comme son prédécesseur de
fragiliser les discussions avec certains
partenaires internationaux